what's next Hills Have Eyes that's right
yeah movie retrospective this week you
know classic Mads it is yeah you know
what's really weird and I think I
mentioned this on one of our sidetrack
shows is that I had already planned to
do hills have eyes for this week because
it was on shutter and I was like Oh weep
that's a classic my head around lo and
behold and lo and behold listener friend
of the show Dominic sent me the deluxe
Blu ray arrow video of the hillside wise
before we even finished watching it on
shutter because I watched a part of it
and then I was like rich and I fell
asleep cuz it was like [ __ ] midnight
now she went over to the blu-ray watched
all the extras and everything and his
good movie man that's a good movie I
realized I saw it I think man when was
the first time I saw this [ __ ] I think I
saw it on VHS that must have been I
think I was in Brazil yeah when I was in
high school probably round 92-86 right
around that yeah it came out in 1977
yeah it was old when I saw it
yeah and I was impressed with it when I
saw it it kind of there's some weird the
weird thing about this one is it's kind
of like it's kind of like Chainsaw
Massacre where it's not real graphic but
a lot of but because the way it sounds
and the way it's shot and the score it
seems a lot more graphic and a lot
scarier than then it really should be
based on what you're seeing yeah I
definitely and and you can tell - I mean
this is only Wes Craven's
I believe it's only his third movie his
first one obviously was Last House on
the Left and then I think he made like
another one in between there that maybe
I can't remember if it was even a horror
movie or not but then he ended up doing
this one and he definitely said that I
mean Texas Chainsaw Massacre was one of
Wes Craven's
favorite movies okay yeah he did and he
definitely wanted to make something that
was a little bit of an homage to that I
guess um so it definitely does have that
70s grindhouse like just that grotty
sleazy you kind of feel to it because it
looks like kind of cheap and it looks
like mostly a snuff film
yeah or crime-scene photos but it's but
there's a lot of [ __ ] hidden into it I
mean it's got its got some did
acting actually is kind of good yeah
it's gonna you know time and even
alright we've got to set it up this
movie is basically almost kind of like a
Mad Max road warrior or a Mad Max kind
of post-apocalyptic type story about
some city people it's you know it's
regular family out middle of nowhere run
into some BAM damn [ __ ] like
post-apocalyptic cavemen they're
cannibals do they talk yeah they're wild
men feral fans yeah yeah of people and
they're robbing travelers and eating
them and they're like raping them and
raping them and eating them too and
they're just like from another [ __ ]
planet yeah I mean they they don't they
don't know much about the outside world
I guess they're kind of isolated
I guess they kind of have their own
little worries but kind of hidden in
this story you know all their names are
the names like Greek gods like Jupiter
and Mercury you know in Mars and Mars
and there is kind of like almost kind of
like a greco-roman kind of story going
between like the Titans you know the
evil gods and [ __ ] like that's Connell
you yeah that's an interesting way of
looking as Chronos is eating his son and
there's all that kind of [ __ ] yeah Wes
Craven did bring that up yeah that go
ahead painting very fun the old gods
that the Romans and the Greeks played in
the old Titans you know they got retired
because they were too evil yeah a plate
you know even though they're not named
after Titans but they're kind of still
kind of like the Titans they're named
after you know Drummond gods to butter
and [ __ ] Jupiter's dad was a [ __ ]
tank it was Italian yeah and you know
the Titans were would eat each other you
know and [ __ ] like that so that's kind
of what to me it was kind of like they
were talking about that joy yes well the
thing about Wes Craven is that even
though I mean he kind of gets saying
he's a horror director and a lot of his
early films like Last House on the Left
which we reviewed a while back and this
one it's like he kind of got um you know
that he makes like these exploitation or
like super violent movies which he does
but you have to think that wes craven he
started out as a professor and a lot of
his movies you know as quote-unquote
sleazy or violent as they may be
actually do have some sort of deeper
themes or deeper ideas behind
them it's like he apparently got the
idea for this like I said and we watched
him there's a there's a really good
interview with him that's on the blu-ray
where he's talking about kind of his
inspirations for this like I said he
really liked Texas Chainsaw Massacre he
also liked The Grapes of Wrath
you know the novel and wanted to do
something along those lines but he was
also talking a little bit about Greek
mythology and about how how those
stories like still hang around is
because the themes like still resonate
so he wanted to do something about that
how he got the specific idea for this
was he was he went to the New York
Public Library evidently and he was
looking through like just all their
their [ __ ] up [ __ ] section I guess
paper all the the horrible crime and
stuff was and he started reading about
and I think we did a show about I don't
think we did a whole entire show about
this topic but we did one that was like
stories that movies were based on the
Scottish cannibal clan of Sunni bean or
Shawnee bean which was a very similar
thing their idea it was like an incest
incestuous family that lived in a cave
like he got lost somewhere yeah like the
water would come up and nobody knew
where they were trying to come in 6th
century 17th century I can't remember
and they were supposedly that was their
thing like every time there was
travelers like on the road or whatever
they would just come out and like kill
and eat them and that's how they
survived yeah and he got fascinated by
the fact that once the family got caught
he found it very like sort of morbidly
amusing that when they got caught
they're like the authorities did pretty
much the same [ __ ] to them like to
punish them as they were doing each
other we you know they put him on the
rack and like burned him alive and [ __ ]
like that so he just found it very
interesting that the civilized people
were uncivil we're doing the same [ __ ]
that they were punishing the uncivilized
guys we're doing that was his opinion
though yeah if you asked me a lot of
these [ __ ] that we're talking
about the [ __ ] that they do the little
kids a little [ __ ] well yeah animals
and you know little kittens and [ __ ] no
I'd [ __ ] you up too that's what I know
what the authorities did to that
particular family it made sense and in
the in the context in the constant at a
time because they went while these
[ __ ] are savage we're gonna do
some Old Testament [ __ ] some yeah I can
tell that's that's what they did to him
and I can see how you know the thing
about The Hills Have Eyes whether or not
he was intentionally trying to make a
statement about you know these
quote-unquote civilized people that
break down in the desert and then become
like a victim to this family who for
their part yes they were trying to
survive yes they had been cast out by
their dad Fred who was the guy that
owned the you know the the gas station
or whatever because they were but they
were cast out because they were feral
because Jeter was he was a horrible he's
born like a monster he said right and so
like he just like cast him out and then
like he went and formed a family and any
good what's weird is that the they
called him Papa Jupiter
his his dad hit him in the head with an
axe and thought he killed him and left
him out in a desert but he survived yes
we had like this big like yeah the
makeups kind of cheesy but you know you
get the idea and they called him Papa
jupiter and he had all these kids and
and he is kind of like a roman god or a
greek god or a titan to him you know
there there's those dynamics but he's
real tyrannical to them getting orders
and they're trying to live up to him and
you know and then the brothers are in
competition for you know brownie points
to Papa you know and then there's
another family-themed it was kind of
cool is that they got this girl hit Papa
Jupiters daughter Ruby his name Ruby and
I guess she's like the jewel of the
family there was no Greek goddess named
Ruby but she was trying to get out of it
yeah because she was like the only one
with a conscience yes she was kind of
like pretty cave girl with bad teeth
that was the not around real fast real
late
I liked her little costume and [ __ ] you
know you could tell they're they're
trying to play up the fact that you know
she had nice legs
[ __ ] yes she got she actually got the
job partially because she could run
faster than any of the other actresses
that tried out because there's so much
running involved in the movie yeah her
character I thought ruby was one of the
most interesting care disparities asking
trying to trade with her granddad and
she's trying to looking around eyes
darting around you know like don't you
make noise and you watch you guys know
just got a body you know
she is like a fun and you know what's
funny it's I didn't even realize this
until we were watching the movie and
then like there was an interview with
her there was an interview with like
pretty much all the actors Michael
Berryman was on there who seems who
always seemed like a delightful human
being but there was an interview with
her and I was like god damn it I was
like she's so familiar and she must have
been in some other movies so we looked
up her IMDB page that was the same
goddamn woman that was in the incredible
melting man that was in like that was
like the redneck chick that was coming
back from the movies and then the
melting man like attacked the trailer
and everything and I was like holy [ __ ]
I never my mind was blown she's a
b-movie scream queen she's been yeah
she's been in a bunch of [ __ ] but that's
where that's where I recognize her from
because incredible melting man was on
MST so I've seen that movie probably
like a hundred times so she's probably
you know making making a living on the
dam circuit you know signing autographs
this way you would think all the more
conventions that's where a lot of these
people make their money but I did like
the fact that I did like her story arc
of that character especially in the
alternate ending of the movie which is a
different edit and it has a couple
seconds of a new scene that kind of
shows that ruby was redeemed that she
did yeah she was able to get out of
there
and I liked that fact that Craven threw
that in there because he's shown an evil
monstrous family all right they're in in
in life there are many evil and
monstrous families just because maybe
you're born into something like that
doesn't mean that you're without hope
yeah that you can't get out of she got
out of there yeah and there's a lot of
people that have escaped [ __ ]
monstrous [ __ ] families not this
monstrous but pretty [ __ ] monstrous
so I like the fact that he put that in
there yeah dad just because your
family's [ __ ] up doesn't having to do
with you yeah you can like get out of
[ __ ] yeah I mean it makes it harder
obviously but you know yeah so it's
interesting that because if you've seen
like I guess the theatrical cut it ends
actually kind of abruptly right with you
know the the one character like up from
the nice family from Ohio and you get a
low-down nice family first though nice
family is like a older man and woman
it's my stepdad and something this Bob
yeah Big Bob is that's where my stepdad
was he
[ __ ] dick he wasn't O'Shea so you see
that dude good that's my [ __ ] step
this I got my stepdad it was exactly
yeah I like one of them Sonny Bono and
his hot girlfriend and that's his wife
Judy Wallace they have a baby dude the
dude look just like Sonny Bono he does
and then you got the gay Luke Skywalker
and his girlfriend and I list his sister
is his sister those ghosts are the world
to me I don't know they never mention it
it's not totally obvious but to me I
just gone that's a gay dude yeah it
might have been they like they
interviewed the actor it's hard to tell
you know hard to sell what were that was
he supposed to be gay or is he just a
gay actor and it wasn't and it was
coming and he was just being himself so
I kind of think it was both yeah but it
worked
yeah he had that damn 45 and he was
fighting to protect his [ __ ] family
he did a lot of [ __ ] brave [ __ ] yeah
I liked that character but he was
basically Luke Skywalker in many ways he
did look very Mark Hamill he look like
Mark Hamill they had that damn that look
was real popular in the 70s and that was
kind of like the blond [ __ ] young guy
you know I mean that's that was a type
an archetype magnet just just like they
had the Burt Reynolds type which yeah
they needed a Burt Reynolds in this
actually
well the fanny boner guy cuz it was a
little bit he had battery he had the
mustache now he was he was Sonny Bono
but I was gonna say that I mean I liked
so you have like the nice family and the
fucked-up family and Wes Craven was kind
of like well I wanted them to be kind of
like mirror images of each other but the
thing about it was that the cannibal
family were terrible I mean other than
brooby it's like yes they need to just
survive yes you know that one guy got
thrown out I guess by his dad when he
was a kid and stuff like that but that's
a really excuse like all the [ __ ] that
they did because it's like they come and
like invade this poor families trailer
they rape the blonde girl and then they
kill Dee Wallace they kill the mom and
then they steal the baby and they're
gonna eat the baby yeah he called it a
turkey yeah
yeah and it's like well do you know that
West crave is a lot of comedy in this
movie as more of it as this [ __ ] is and
really the [ __ ] evil family and there
was funnies there on a mount like Mount
Olympus in a way yeah even though but
they shot it in Mojave does what I think
they're that the whole Greek thing about
being up in a mountain might be going
back to the Titans and the [ __ ] gods
and [ __ ] it could possibly be as part of
it because I do think Wes Craven was
like aware of that I mean he did talk
yeah some about like Greek mythology and
stuff when he was talking about this a
mythological tale to have like a [ __ ]
mythological background in the same way
as star wars had a mythological
background so yeah Britain so in that
way it's a well-crafted tale yeah it's
well executed I mean it's a grind house
flick but that's a genre now yeah so the
movies aged real well it's better now
than it was I mean it's obviously this
glorious stuff like that isn't isn't
shocking like it was in 1977 it doesn't
but it doesn't really need that cuz it
still has that like Riddhi like I said
that's why it's hard to replicate movies
that came out in the 70s like Texas
Chainsaw Massacre and stuff yes you can
wear make them and yes you know even the
Texas Chainsaw Massacre was okay but
it's not you can't capture that same
time period you can't capture like that
snuff film like I shouldn't be watching
this yeah you like I'm feeling yeah and
it's like yeah it's down to the little
details the [ __ ] Cana mediocre film
quality the the edits brup edits you
could tell it's kind of a crude edit
between cuts yeah Wes Craven edited as
well yeah fine you can tell it's
old-fashioned technology that they're
you'd that they're working with the
little details stuff that's up in the
dam camper you know I mean what kind of
bag of cookies that they're eating it
was all [ __ ] we remembered as kids you
go you just can't that bag of cookies
and animal crackers I remember those
with like with the icing on I'm yet a
pink pink and white that pink like that
hard icing like the fondant type I say
yeah it's a little tiny [ __ ] colored
dots on them that that's what that's
what man I really show the top of that
package I forgot all about it
that bag [ __ ] were delicious they
really were I was like many many more
crumbly butter butter with icing on it
guys they were really good as they were
and it's just like really funny I had
forgotten all about them but as soon as
we saw that bag I was like yeah but yeah
so one thing - Wes Craven actually
wanted the family to eat the baby or to
kill the baby yeah and apparently all
the cast rebelled they're like no we
don't think that's a good idea I think
it's fine we're not doing that because
there was something to save yeah because
I mean the whole point of the thing and
what I was getting to before was that
yes these families could be seen as
mirror images of each other like the
civilized family the uncivilized family
I [ __ ] like that but if that said though
I'm not sure like how clear that
distinction is because the cannibal
family are clearly bad and the good
family only do what they do because
they're fighting to defend their own
family I mean the you know Sonny Bono is
just like the Sonny Bono guy is like you
know fighting to get his baby back I
mean these people killed his wife they
raped his sister-in-law and they stole
his baby yeah um so yes you were gonna
go get medieval on these [ __ ]
right um not because you're a bad person
but because you had to you have to
another good thing about this movies
this movie was a birth of a [ __ ]
screen legend Michael what's Michael's
last name Michael Barry meant Michael
Berryman Michael Berryman is a very
strange-looking fellow man he looks like
he's like something out of a heavy metal
magazine remember the [ __ ] top comic
book heavy metal yeah he looked like
something out of his very elongated head
he was born with some birth defects yeah
he has a several more than two-dozen
birthday fair and he's had he's been in
a lot of movies uh uh he was in [ __ ]
weird science yeah he's in that what
else is he in he with you see the guy
you know who it is I'm talking about I
mean he's immediately recognize this guy
on the on on the poster of The Hills
Have Eyes and that sold this [ __ ]
movie well he's an icon now probably
really
yes oh I mean he has like a horror
career because of this maybe and he said
that as well with this she can he could
get any other kind of horror movies he
shows so everybody knows who this dude
is evidently he's extremely popular on
the damn Horicon [ __ ] circuit I
probably do it very well for himself and
you'd look at him and he's he's [ __ ]
what's funny is that you look at the
dude you go that's not a good looking
man but there's something kind of cute
about it really I kind of like in the
way that damn cat so these cats that you
see with like grumpy cat like grumpy cat
like something kind of like that he's
got a [ __ ] kind of a cool look to him
in a way he looks like a like a mutant
of some sort which I guess he's got
medical problems I don't that makes you
a mutant but he's just kind of a [ __ ]
and they say he's just a nicest kind of
world you I heard that I friend make a
very very intelligent you know he's got
at least above-average intelligence from
from what I'm hearing you know if
they're his interviews so he's famous
for looking like that
yeah and evidently like a lot of [ __ ]
behind he's very popular evidently
behind the scene you know when he he had
a scene we had to rape this good-looking
blonde they blonde girl yeah and in
order to break the ice and [ __ ] where
they had the curtain or these new were
rehearsing the rape but they were doing
it as if it was a [ __ ] love seemed
well yeah because they said everyone's
really you know you're uptight about
everybody well you know nobody likes to
really have to like Roma rape scene
because it's kind of uncomfortable for
the whole crew busting up pull the
curtains back in funky and they're all
making like a hot chick and make it out
doing this ticket thing that kind of
broke the ice and it helped the [ __ ]
help them film that scene which you know
they were there one comfortable filming
that scene you know yeah cuz you know
they were all working together but you
know maybe they didn't know each other
though that well yeah I can see how that
would be a little squicky
so and they say well the thing about
Michael bare him into one of his birth
defects is that unfortunately for him on
this shoot is that he was born without
sweat glands yeah and they were filming
in the Mojave Desert which was about 120
degrees during the day and it was like
12 to 14 hour days
because it was only like a three week
shoot or something so it's like yeah he
was uh I think they had to have like
some medical personnel on hand so he
wouldn't like keel over dead or whatever
so on the back of that I prize him
Michael seemed to have a way with women
he probably did I feel like I said he
seems like very charming yeah I always
thought he was you know he's aged very
well according to be yeah I'm not sure
when I mean because the interviews he
looks as young as he did yeah he doesn't
look that much different on that way the
interviews that were on the blu-ray I'm
not sure how old they were because they
had Wes Craven was on there and he
passed away obviously several years ago
so I'm not sure how old those interviews
were um and this D Wallace to this might
have been her first movie or her first
kind of major movie and she kind of got
into horror like on the back of this as
well because she was also in the howling
and she was a Cujo yeah watch it I'm
going mad no that is she was st wallace
yes I know but where do I recognize her
from and she's like I don't know she's
been in so many movies I said Cujo he
cujo's like I don't really remember and
remember her from that and it's
something else that she does what
howling oh yeah of course
she played the reporter man yeah yeah
and we believed that howling day didn't
quite click yeah she was cute she was
adorable
but yeah so I feel like this is probably
her first one and you know this movie I
think this movie ended up costing
costing three times more than Last House
on the Left which was paid for like a
buck 98 I have to say but I think this
movie Wes Craven couldn't give an exact
amount I think it was 750,000 so it was
it was under a million for sure and it
made 25 million so it wasn't like I was
huge like breakout success or anything
like that but it made like a lot of
money and I feel like you know Wes
Craven on the back of this and you know
Last House on the Left he kind of got a
reputation of being a [ __ ] director
later on obviously he did like Nitra and
I'm sure eat and scream and all that
kind of stuff the funny thing too is I
was looking so I was like I know you
know all the big movies that he's done
and we've reviewed a couple of his movie
did surf in the rainbow and and people
under the stairs but I had forgotten
that he had also directed like
thing and he also did vampire in
Brooklyn I totally forgot that Wes
Craven directed that movie interestingly
to one of his lesser-known movies mind
Ripper was actually supposed to be a
third Hills Have Eyes movie but then
they just changed it up I mean cuz he
made that like they made a sequel which
I think I saw a long time ago and wasn't
really all that impressed with and then
they were gonna make a third one like he
wanted to make a third one but then they
didn't end up doing it so he ended up
doing mind Ripper instead which was the
script for the third one but then they
changed it around so it wasn't a similar
another thing about this movie that we
got to mention is the the score this has
a fantastic score it is very good the
limitations of the time they did not
have synthesizers so this is a all
acoustic instruments weird ass and it's
it's ugly
and it's made ugly on purpose because
[ __ ] what's happened especially in
context at the time of this movie's
being written and performed this was
some [ __ ] bizarre [ __ ] that nobody's
ever seen before so the guy who did the
[ __ ] score made sure that this was
weird eerie it sounds a bit like
synthesizers it's not it's weird string
instruments and it was very well thought
out
I mean he's playing music during times
when the the [ __ ] bad guys are
running and he's looking at the thing
he's seen that the necklaces are
jiggling and it's all got bear claws and
ammunition and [ __ ] bones and teeth
so he says I need those necklaces so I
can rattle them so that's in the song
yeah and he said the actual necklaces
yeah with with the [ __ ] rhythm of
them run this actually helped him get
like the rhythm to the music in the back
so the movie is just all-around very
well-crafted I mean though if this movie
had been done wrong it would have been
for God but it was remembered because
the people that worked on I cared about
it they didn't have a lot of money but
they thought about what they were doing
and they maximized their performances
whatever they whoever whatever job they
had they were really trying to do it to
the best of their abilities and it
because of that you can feel the soul in
this movie that's what I because that's
why I think
movies like these like a lot of Wes
Craven's movies even though on the
surface if you don't really you know if
you just give them kind of a cursory
watch or you're not really into horror
movies or whatever you can be like oh
it's just some like you know
exploitation movie from the 70s or it's
just like a bunch of violence for the
sake of it but it's really not and you
know people people that are into horror
can tell the difference between ones
that are just like a [ __ ] knock off
that nobody gave a [ __ ] about that they
were just trying to make a buck off of
and ones that actually had an idea
behind them but a lot of thought behind
them and a lot of work and love put into
them because they were trying to like
they had a particular vision they were
trying to you know convey Donne peak was
the name of the guy that did the score
there is an interview with him on the
Blu ray which was one of my favorite
interviews that we watched he seemed he
was like super enthusiastic about like
the music and everything and yeah they
had like probably like a 10 or 15 minute
interview with him and he was gonna buy
sure we heard it he's good he's like I
don't know then we convinced him and I'm
glad that he with that score cuz that
score fits it it really does fit yeah it
stood up to the test of time
yeah I mean you can watch the movie now
and you still get kind of a weird eerie
eerie kind of feeling and the - I think
um you know the setting helps a lot
because I mean obviously they actually
did go out to this [ __ ] middle of
nowhere in the Mojave Desert yeah and
kind of camped out there and film whole
movie yeah they said it was like super
hot in the day obviously like really
cold at night they were living in the
gruff conditions and it was because they
cared about the movie they tried to make
the movie the best they could possibly
could yeah and it was all new actors and
all new kind of crew that hadn't really
been around and blasio young some of
them had worked on Roger Corman movies
but that's about it and they're just
trying to make this [ __ ] cool flick
you know so they could be remembered by
and they did yeah and a lot of people
ended up this helped and they're just
helping their career a lot of people now
the Sonny Bono guy he didn't he had no
idea that it was gonna be that big yeah
cuz they cuz he had his own like
interview where he was talking about
like I didn't realize this was you know
there's always one of those - one or two
guys that was like I didn't think people
would really give a [ __ ] about this yeah
well it's funny because you know like I
said and I think nowadays cuz people
that are into horror and like watch like
old ones
then you know you go and see the person
that was in it like at the convention or
whatever but you have to think like for
the actor that was just like a job that
they had when they were like although
it's like a long time ago and it's like
they just like yeah I just needed a job
at a paycheck and it's like then they
probably didn't even think about it
again and instead and in the 70s science
fiction and horror was considered like a
[ __ ] loser
it was lowbrow loser [ __ ] you like I
said it was like it was like a step
above porn pretty edge and it was gonna
be something that only kids watched and
it was John can you never see it again
yeah which is very funny and I'm glad
that that stigma has fallen away but it
really did have that stink about it even
into the 80s I think like cuz of all the
slasher movies and that helped it though
I think but yeah 80s that was like the
golden era and that the Golden Age is
what made horror yeah it wouldn't and I
think it's because it was just the right
guys the right place at the right time
at the right level of Technology yeah
that you could make a [ __ ] and and
then an audience that hadn't seen it yet
had never seen that before living
through the golden era of it [ __ ] was
the best yeah I'm glad that I'm not in
20 years old having to go back and look
at that [ __ ] now cuz I probably wouldn't
like it well you wouldn't I liked it
because you didn't live through the
context of context to the time because
you're gonna remember what [ __ ] was like
back then right and it does give like an
added residence and I'm not saying that
like younger people can't get into oh
because I know like a lot of younger
people that are in their 20s and 30s and
really into that old [ __ ] it was just
back in the 70s in the 80s
this [ __ ] was so ahead of what else of
what was going on it was it was so
different oh yeah definitely
it was subversive and a lot of were
certain it was miles ahead of what
mainstream entertainment was doing I
mean there was good mainstream entertain
but most of it was garbage yeah
yeah if you wanted like the really good
[ __ ] you had to kind of go Glee
underground stuff alternate media type
of stuff I should mention before we wrap
up that there was a remake of this I
believe it came out in 2006 I saw this
alright I'm sorry the remake isn't bad
actually it was done by um Alexander aha
the famed French extremity new French
except it's not a dress movie though
it's a know it
it's just kind of like an updated it
still had kind of has like the hillbilly
horror type you know they got a ready to
it but there's radiation because so
these are actual like radiated mutants
rather than just like people that got
chucked out in the forest earlier than
caves and went feral and it's a modern
movie
it's just wait gory er but it's
different it is does it does not have
this tone yeah it's more like a reboot
slash sequel or something like that or
inspired by yeah it'd be like trying to
compare the Walking Dead with night or
Living Dead be like that in there both
sobbing movies but not a living dead was
not modern yeah it's kind of hard for me
to that's why that's why I think I've
never done anything like oh my Jenni's
top hunter horror movies or anything
like that because it's really hard for
me to say one movie is better than
another one is the content because
they're well and a lot of them are so
different from one another it's like in
particularly horror which is such a wide
genre I mean you have so many different
subgenres that are completely different
from each other it might as well be a
completely different film genre really
the remake of The Hills Have Eyes
technically in special effects and just
edit and way it flows is better than
this one
I didn't like it better though yes
actually like the original game you know
it was more crude Driehaus it was the
original yeah and and it was like that
it's like comparing Star Trek The Next
Generation and the original series it's
both Star Trek but there's some about
that original series yeah it's just some
about that original I still I like them
both I still love the original the
original series just I like the other I
like the newer ones too like I like some
of the newer shows and I like the you
know but some of the you know the movies
but it's really like I liked only like
the first two JJ Abrams movies not only
kinda they they're taking Star Trek into
the action genre yeah but I feel like
that's sort of happening with everything
they did that with a lot of horror
remakes and they did that little they're
trying to make everything like a big
action movie yes stupid
our Trek and going on Star Trek here we
go
is a character based movie it's a
mythology it's about relationships
between characters that you love yeah
and it's and then working together and
solving problems it's not an action
movie well yeah and that's what I liked
about that's why whenever I feel like
watching Star Trek and I just want to
like have a drink or you know like a cup
of coffee or something like that and sit
down and watch some Star Trek it's
always gonna be original series yeah cuz
it's like I don't give a [ __ ] I don't
really give a [ __ ] about the aliens and
monsters nothing like that I just want
to watch Spock and bones sniping at each
end if you like okay I got a plug I got
like pluck V I got a plug Vic magnet Vic
Bickman manyanya if you like the
original series you gotta see Star Trek
continues it's all for its free it's
right there on YouTube it is the [ __ ]
final season of the original series Vic
does a great [ __ ] in Captain Kirk
[ __ ] Todd haberkorn does suck in
Spock the dude who played [ __ ] Scotty
what was his name
I played the original Scotty his son
plays the new Scotty yeah it's just and
it's a lot of same people that did
writing and worked on the original
series worked on this too yeah
so I Star Trek contains a Star Trek
continues plug yeah in the middle in the
middle of the hills very weird but I can
see how we got there because like you
said I quite liked The Hills Have Eyes
remake I like a lot of that new French
extremity uh you know Harper's I like
all the gore and stuff into it um it's
good I I didn't you know I didn't mind
the Texas Chainsaw Massacre remake but
you're never it's never gonna be the
same as that I can enjoy them as two
different movies types of movies yeah um
but I don't really see one is like being
you know oh I'm remaking this one like
it you know what I mean because you
still have both you're never gonna
recapture the tone of 1974 you're never
gonna recapture the tone of 1977 it's
you just can't do it because nobody
we don't live back then now so you know
and you know we just remember it it's in
our memories and people that weren't
born then
that have no idea can you focus you can
can evoke it okay VFW did evoke the 80's
yeah it did have 80s carpenter yeah if
you like 80s carpenter
if you FW you need to see that movie
that's very much escape from New York
slash him assault on precinct 13 it is
in a little bit more of a more modern
context but that's not the world they're
talking about yeah they're talking about
carpenters early 1980s that's what
they're talking about
instead of late seventies yeah talking
about and like you said I've seen I have
seen some horror movies that were set in
the 70s or said in the 80s that were
very good at like you said invoking that
time period and having lived through
that time period you know we can tell
when somebody's just trying it not and
not doing it working and what is not but
you know what I mean but so I'm just
saying that it's it's just harder to do
in the sense that I don't want to say
that it's always going to be a pastiche
because you didn't actually make it
during that time period yeah but I'm
watching VFW and scene for scene I just
feel get this weird feeling then I'm
watching assault on precinct 13 the
feeling that I'm watching escape from
New York and the fog I'm watching all
those movies but this is a new movie and
I haven't seen it yeah but it's those
which is what is one of those yeah it
was perfect the tone and everything out
if felt like a [ __ ] carpenter was
doing them [ __ ] score yeah felt like
some of the guys in the bar somehow
survived the [ __ ] the Antarctic
expedition thing like one of those guys
might have been on that next this is the
way it felt to me and I don't have a
problem at all with modern filmmakers
wanting to evoke that time period as
long as they do it success is you know
how to do it yeah and I've seen a lot of
ones that were like that yeah and you
kind of have to not have money if the
less money I have the more you will live
folk well and they're more creative the
more creative yeah sometimes limitations
are good yeah you know like if where you
have if you have all the money in the
world sometimes you get lazy because
yeah you're not gonna [ __ ] that right is
that Terminator 1 there's no money there
boy that was a [ __ ] awesome movie
awesome [ __ ] movie - but today if
that wasn't the union picture you can
make it for next another that movie made
all kinds of [ __ ] money the whole
franchise on the back of Terminator 1
why that was a good story yeah and it
was a lot of limitations that they
worked around and it was based on it was
a rip and extent the Terminator was a
ripoff of an even worse movie called the
exterminator yeah what they said I've
never seen that movie but they said that
that movie was terrible but it but you
can do that yeah because I mean if
you're an artist long as you don't rip
stuff off like directly I mean because
I've seen like lots of movies that you
know especially ones from like the 50s
or 60s or whatever and you see ones in
your and I'm like man that's a great
idea it's too bad it was like 1955 and
they didn't have any money like to do
this because they could have really done
this idea really cool like if you take
something like that and remake it and
like change it up a little bit then I
don't have a problem with that at all
I was gonna say when you were talking
about making a [ __ ] ton of money Hills
Have Eyes actually like I said did make
25 million on a budget of less than a
million
they said it probably would have made
more except it's like it went into
limited release and then it was like
really successful like it made two
million like on its limited release so
they wider released it and then as soon
as they released it widely like around
the country was a chef in know Smokey
and the Bandit which we had to see that
again and everybody went to see smokey
in the Bandit so it's like it almost
kind of got buried underneath Smokey and
the Bandit the will the other day when
we were talking about Jim uh smoking
well we're talking about Jim Bob's
drive-in and he was doing 24 hours of
redneck joy and smoking the band it was
one of the ones gotta see gotta get
smoked in a band and getting a cannibal
I saw this - 50 70 times on your
sentence if you if you all send us those
movies will do haha I grew up watching
them think oh I used to love that [ __ ] I
know how it stands up though yeah we
might see it now and be like like what
the [ __ ] yeah um I haven't had that
happen too much like every now and then
I'll see something like yeah and and
like I'll be like God what the [ __ ] did
I see in that movie but most of the time
like when I see one that I liked as a
kid I'm just like
watch I thought I had a ball run is a
little kid
Cannonball Run and you know sitting up
on the [ __ ] bed [ __ ] poor and
[ __ ] saw the peanuts in my coca-cola
RC RC RC cryo RC Cola porn salted
peanuts in it drinking and eating it
this is why she can't have all right you
can't about where I couldn't get any
more southern than that [ __ ] yeah it's
pretty southern all right were you
eating - Moon Pie - yeah anyway so if
you haven't seen the original Hills Have
Eyes like I said the remake is good - um
but you know if you love that [ __ ]
grotty seventies grind house type of
aesthetic you really can't beat the
original so definitely go check it out
if you haven't seen it the blu-ray from
arrow video is very red and it has like
a whole bunch of extra stuff on it yeah
it's worth getting a blue it's
definitely worth getting so yeah I
really recommend it